hello steve kaufman here
i want to talk today about uh why i
think multilingualism is coming sooner
rather than later
i did a recent
video cam here where i i spoke in a
number of languages got a very good
response i can always do this again
um i forgot italian i could do italian
but i won't i won't interfere with my
with my discussion today if there's a
request i can always uh chat a bit in
italian about
about why language learning has to be
fun and why it's really not a big deal
and why we are we are
all able to learn languages we all learn
our first language we learn it because
it isn't taught the way second languages
are taught so we have a better chance of
learning it and enjoying it
but uh so
speaking a number of languages is really
not a big deal if it's done properly
uh but the big obstacle has been this
sort of
sense that that english is the the
dominant
international language and why bother
with other languages if we all learn
english we can all communicate
and of course that's been the
conventional wisdom everywhere in the
world
but you know the one thing about
conventional wisdoms is
that they do have a tendency to change
and and we are
not very good at predicting the future
because
all people ever do is is extrapolate the
past into the future
so we don't really see the big changes
that are coming
but it's certainly true that the first
world war
was a major contributor
to
the
call it the disintegration
of
the european colonies
uh the second world war kind of put a a
nail in the coffin uh as as the rest of
the world looked at the europeans and
saw them
beating each other up and slaughtering
each other and
said now why are we part of
you know uh an empire belonging to those
people when they're so stupid
so
that was i think a major part of a
change in attitude that that led to uh
to decolonization
they're gonna
hazard a prediction here that the uh
collapse of the world financial system
and of course the crisis that we're in
right now it didn't begin with the
subprime mortgage problem in the united
states
uh
there were other factors at play there
was a
you know a drop in industrial production
in a number of countries prior to
september 2008
we had the effect of the
ridiculously high prices of oil and of
course people were predicting even
higher prices for oil
these were inflationary
factors so banks started pulling back on
credit and the main thing is that there
was a suddenly a feeling that things
aren't right people lost confidence
there was uncertainty and so everything
is kind of collapsing i mean it'll
eventually write itself
but the perception is that that the
problem originated with the united
states
and to some extent the english-speaking
world
and that the english-speaking
world with an emphasis on consumerism
and everybody
mortgaged and and sort of borrowing to
the hilt
that this model
as sort of the basis for the world
economy maybe isn't such a good idea
and i think people are going to
increasingly question that model and as
a result they're going to question the
the predominance of the united states
and of the english-speaking world in a
number of fields because they lose
prestige in the economic sphere they
will lose prestige in other spheres as
well so then it may not be such an
obvious given
that english has to be the international
language i mean it's very interesting
when you read history that not only did
the upper class in russia speak french
better than russian
say at the time of at the time when
napoleon invaded russia
but at that time as well because
napoleon also invaded germany
and
in the late 18th century
and the early 19th century i mean france
was by far the dominant country in
europe it was the largest population had
more people than russia
and french
the french language was the model the
french
you know the intellectuals the
enlightenment enlightenment and so forth
all came from france and so germans
the
sort of highly educated germans
spoke french
which is not the case now today they
speak english i mean in sweden german
was the more dominant second language
had a head of
of english earlier in the previous
century so things can change
and if you look around the world
uh i mean in europe there's 100 million
people who speak german
and german is very easy for dutch people
and scandinavians to learn
and germany is a major economic force
it's germany itself and you add in
austria and the german-speaking part of
switzerland that's a dominant economy
uh
and and as you move eastward uh you know
on the continent you get into
of course the countries of eastern
europe which
now of course they're very concerned
about establishing their independence
from russia because it just got out from
under the
the control either as a satellite
country or as a part of the former
soviet union
so the baltic states and poland and the
czech republic and so forth they want to
affirm their independence and learning
english instead of russian is a way of
doing that
however they all speak nicely they'll
speak but russian is quite common
especially in in the countries of the
former soviet union
and when i listened to echamas v and
they interviewed people from georgia
from moldavia from kazakhstan
from latvia i'm just so impressed with
the level of the russia they speak
flawlessly i mean these are politicians
in those countries
so
russian covers a large geographical area
so it whereas it used to be primarily
the language of the soviet union it's
now an international language i mean
turkish
in central asia
i have no idea how mutually
comprehensible uh uyghur and anatolian
turkish is
but between you know uzbekistan and
azerbaijan and turkmenistan and so forth
there's a lot of countries in there and
a lot of geographic space where turkish
is spoken
not to mention arabic which covers north
africa and a good part of the middle
east
hindi which is a common
common language
that's fairly well understood i gather
because i don't speak it uh
in the
south uh in south asia
japanese korean chinese are all quite
different
but at least the japanese and the
koreans have a head start in learning
chinese because they
may not still be the case in korea but
certainly the japanese they have the
chinese characters
uh latin america spanish
the uh
the
sort of latin mediterranean italy france
spain speak essentially the same
language it's not very difficult for
them to to learn the other language so i
mean all of those people today are
happier speaking english that's because
that's the fashion because that's
perceived to be more international and
perhaps there's rivalry maybe the
italian
doesn't want to speak french he'd rather
speak english because
mutually they're trying to be more
arrogant than the other i mean there's
all kinds of reasons but it's all
attitude
so if the attitude changes
if the attitude changes
uh i mean i i
i don't see any reason why we couldn't
have four or five international
languages and part of that is the
recognition that it's not a big deal if
you can speak one second language you
can speak two or three or four
i believe as long as the
teaching methods
and as long as our attitude towards it
changes and
historically
there have been many societies and many
sort of
social classes where it was not at all
unusual for people to speak
three or four languages so my hope is
that we are returning to an era of
multilingualism
and i think that the present crisis and
the people's attitudes towards the
dominant role that the english-speaking
world has played
in in in the world economy and in the
development of of of world affairs and
even in academic affairs that it might
they might suffer english is going to
suffer a loss of prestige
and that might give a chance to other
languages to be considered as at least
regional international languages and all
of that will promote more
multilingualism so that is my little
talk today on
my favorite subject or one of them of
multilingualism thank you for listening